over the course of the next kind of 56
days we are going to hear a lot about
why China needs written that's the whole
point of these trade missions is
basically saying you know we need each
other and therefore you need to do
business with us this stopped one we're
in Beijing this is somewhere called tech
temple you might be expecting somewhere
that's either just like a temple is one
big and grand and in fact this is rather
support of Shoreditch style place where
I want
something is big
now Beijing's now over and we're going
to Shanghai is by early in the morning
okay we're gonna get in this car and
shame higher things a bit hectic
basically ah um what's happened so far
today okay we came from Beijing's
weekend sweater Shanghai and we went to
the stock market listen to george
osborne everywhere we've gone we've had
this enormous police escort hasn't
happened anywhere else make me shut down
all of the streets they got lines of
traffic and then we've kind of gone on
it's true it's getting interesting it's
getting quite controversial because
they're all ? everywhere
tool
they look over here give this sense of
just what it involves following around
the Chancellor but this is being a kind
of bread and butter us wasting hanging
around waiting for a photo opportunity
which that happens and then he moves off
elsewhere it's over we're flying off to
shatter
I question whether this
bubble